[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en la ciudad estadounidense de
seattle para conocer un poco más del
primer museo de arte nfc del mundo
recordemos que nfc son las iniciales de
toquen no fungible un certificado
digital de autenticidad que se asocia a
un único archivo digital en otras
palabras así como en el arte
convencional valoramos la pieza original
en el arte digital el nfc nos indica que
la obra es original pues este espacio
abrió sus puertas en enero y se ha
convertido en un importante escenario
para este tipo de arte porque aunque
muchos podríamos pensar que sólo se
necesita una pantalla para ver una obra
digital lo que ofrece este lugar es
justamente la experiencia de un museo
nos dimos cuenta del impacto de poder
mirar este tipo de arte un lugar en el
que realmente disminuye la velocidad ves
todos los detalles no solo estás
desplazándose por tu teléfono
el museo tiene una programación definida
para todo el año y tiene planes de
continuar educando a sus visitantes
sobre el futuro de los toques no
fungibles puedes hacer un campo
considerablemente reciente en 2021 esta
industria produjo unos 14 mil millones
de dólares se espera que este año la
ganancia sea de más de 21 mil millones
ahora cambiamos de tema y vamos a
ecuador donde un grupo de estudiantes de
la universidad de las américas
desarrolló un prototipo de silla de
ruedas que se controla mentalmente el
aparato cuenta con una diadema que se
pone sobre la frente del paciente y que
recopila y envía datos a un pequeño
computador que los procesa lo que hace
es moverse con
pensamientos es decir nosotros tenemos
una diadema la cual la ponemos en
nuestra frente que recopila información
en nuestro cerebro a través de esta
información nosotros la tratamos de
enviamos un controlador le programamos y
la adaptamos para que logremos hacer
movimientos con distintos pensamientos
tiene un retardo de un segundo
exactamente en recibir y enviar la
información puntualmente a la silla se
desplaza cuando el algoritmo reconoce
que la persona está pensando en un
determinado color y puede moverse
adelante atrás a la izquierda y a la
derecha con una silla de ruedas que sea
donada y con los motores donados por la
universidad los estudiantes pueden
invertir solo 200 dólares en los
elementos restantes sin embargo la
fabricación completa podría costar unos
500 dólares un precio bajo si se compara
con proyectos similares
este tipo de tecnología
no es que es nueva recién salida pero
recién está queriendo implementarse con
con funcionalidades digamos útiles
porque se lo utiliza para juegos o como
le digo para proyectos de prototipos no
tiene una utilidad real que pueda servir
a la comunidad o al mundo entero
continuamos en suecia hablando de
realidad virtual porque el servicio
postal nacional post north está
capacitando al personal con el uso de
visores para simular todo el proceso
desde operar vehículos hasta clasificar
paquetes se trata de una iniciativa que
surgió durante la pandemia cuando el
distanciamiento social obligó a repensar
cómo se podría capacitar velozmente al
nuevo personal
fue una situación especial porque
tuvimos a muchas personas en licencia
por enfermedad al principio de la
pandemia y necesitamos gente porque
transportamos sangre suministros médicos
entregas express correo del gobierno que
necesitaba ser entregado y no había
gente o también un equipo la compañía se
asoció con word ping una empresa de
capacitación con realidad virtual en 3d
para crear una serie de módulos que le
enseñan al personal desde cómo verificar
y mantener sus vehículos levantar
rastrear y procesar paquetes hasta
ciudades de liderazgo
y
muchas personas hablan de realidad
virtual y realidad aumentada en
cuestiones sociales juegos
entretenimiento y swing pero creo que el
beneficio real será en tratamientos
educación y experiencia
[Música]
hemos visto muchas investigaciones
hechas en terapia cognitiva por ejemplo
donde puedes entrenarte en un ambiente
seguro en el que de otra manera no
podrías estar
según post north los datos internos
muestran que la capacitación con
realidad virtual 3d es hasta un 80% más
efectiva que los módulos de aprendizaje
en línea que se usaban anteriormente la
compañía buscará ampliar la cantidad de
visores y módulos para capacitar a
muchos de sus 26.000 empleados
y finalizamos en londres donde se lleva
a cabo una particular muestra de arte
inmersivo se llama future shock y se
desarrolla en un estacionamiento
subterráneo que está diseñado como un
laberinto varias salas cada una con
temática y elementos particulares como
luces proyectores láseres humo y espejos
buscan romper con la cotidianidad de una
exposición y hacer que los asistentes
vivan con al menos cuatro de sus cinco
sentidos una experiencia diferente
creo que esta exhibición realmente no
aplica a los estándares comunes porque
hay arte hay diseño hay tecnología y
creo que eso es lo que buscan los
creadores así que si eres de las
personas que les gusta las artes duras
podrías pensar no estoy obteniendo
ningún significado de las piezas pero
creo que eso es lo que ellos quieren que
quede es inmenso y veas lo que la
tecnología puede hacer así llegamos al
final de este espacio a ustedes les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
a